in general ncis is not the kind of show
that carries plot lines over from week
to week
the series has a crime procedural and as
such there's typically a new case each
week that the team has to solve
while stories may not carry over through
successive episodes
certain character details do remain
constant we're not suddenly going to see
special agent leroy jethro gibbs start
giving soliloquies any time
soon the leader and former marine
gunnery sergeant is going to remain a
man of few words
and let his piercing gays do most of the
talking it's his personality
has shaped through the life he's lived
before and during his time on the major
case response team
these details are subtle reminders of
how the show's central players have been
changed by the things they've gone
through and they reinforce the idea that
while the team is always taking new
cases
the characters don't forget all the
things they've been through together
the same can be said for everyone's
favorite wilshere return or not
character
ziva david played by cody de pablo her
prior life and her time alongside the
ntis team has shaped her personality
in fact one case in particular had a
noticeable impact on her wardrobe
the case in question was investigated in
the 16th episode of ntis
season 4 entitled dead man walking this
ncis episode featured a navy lieutenant
named royce sanders
who shows up in the mcrt bullpen and
isn't looking too good
he's coming to the team with a simple
request to solve a murder
his own murder in fact no he's not a
ghost visiting them from beyond
the grave as he demonstrates by removing
a clump of hair
roy has realized he's been poisoned with
radiation and will meet an untimely end
it turns out he works at the
international atomic energy agency
but doesn't believe his sickness is mere
occupational hazard
the team manages to suss out how roy's
been poisoned abby isolates radioactive
ash from a shooting range
and ducky posits that the thalium has
been laced into roy's cigars but the
team can't seem to figure out a motive
that is until gibbs puts together that
roy is due to go to uzbekistan to
inspect a nuclear reactor
given that it made a similar trip six
times previously
it's likely that he would have noticed
the changes that have been made recently
changes that appear to be geared toward
re-establishing a soviet-era weapons
program at the site
all it takes is a 50 000 bribe to iaea
admin holly stegmann for her to poison
roy sadly her goal was to simply prevent
him from making the inspection trip
and she's dismayed to learn he's dying
roy sanders and zeva david form a close
bond over the course of the episode
in part because eva actually recognizes
him but can't figure out why at first
tony denozzo wonders if it could be from
her past with mossad
eventually she realizes that she's seen
him running and the two bond over having
similar fathers and other life
experiences
i pass you every morning i'm going east
you're going west don't you recognize me
the ncis team is ultimately able to
solve roy's murder
but he eventually succumbs to the
thalian poisoning he already knew would
kill him
the navy lieutenant doesn't survive the
episode but before he dies
the bond he forms with zeva clearly
makes a lasting impression on her
one that would carry over into
subsequent episodes after roy's death in
dead man walking
zebra is seen wearing an orange beanie
some fans believe that it's actually
roy's old running attire
you're the one who wears the fluorescent
orange watch cap it's a devastating
episode
in part because roy had quickly
established himself as a likable
character
and as someone with whom ziva had a real
connection the fact that zeva seems to
wear his beanie following his death
speaks to that connection and to the
fact that although the ncis team has
moved on to other cases
the show's characters still remember the
cases that had the biggest impact on
them
that orange beanie became a regular part
of zeva's identity
and although it's a subtle detail it's
one that fans on reddit noticed and
appreciated for what it represented
every ncis character develops their own
history as a result of the cases the
team takes on
even if they're not always explicitly
acknowledged check out one of our newest
videos right here plus
even more looper videos about ntis are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one